a mother of a child with special needs
is now taking action against the clark
county school district and today she
filed a federal lawsuit alleging some
major failures and now the eight news
now i team has also uncovered other
failures at the state level the mom
first spoke with vanessa murphy who has
more on what she's learned
courtney larson says her son who has
autism came home from school with
injuries like this one under his eye but
he couldn't express what happened
because at the time he was three years
old and non-verbal she tells the eight
news now i-team she eventually received
a call from the sandra thompson
elementary school principal about
allegations against teacher melissa
olchesky she hurt my son
larson filed this federal lawsuit
wednesday against olcheske the clark
county school district and the school
principal alleging negligence
discrimination and violation of the
disabilities act and more larson spoke
with the i-team via zoom from florida
where she's relocated the system
completely failed
me as a mother my son as as a child with
with a disability
attorney called dune baghdadi is
representing larson i think one one real
important issue here is that the laws
that are on the books are there to
protect people but they can't protect
people if they're not followed according
to the lawsuit school leaders received
reports of olcheske's ongoing
mistreatment of students with
disabilities but failed to document and
investigate the allegations and failed
to notify the nevada department of
education the i-team obtained a
recording of an initial phone call by
school principal sean holland another
employee saw the teacher hit the
three-year-old kid the kid's non-verbal
has the parent been notified no
should i also call cps i think that's
what emr told me yeah
yeah i don't it should be in your crisis
plan but yeah oh that's a good question
that's a good point this is police body
camera video of a school employee being
interviewed about olszewski's treatment
of multiple students laugh on the arm
for sure
and how many times
i've seen it
one slap on the arm
and then the finger slapping right here
yeah pulling her down into the seat
while screaming
screaming your face sit down and then
alchesky is interviewed by police have
you ever
flicked a student
towards the hands from the arm
fingers
yeah that i think that tapping might
have you know
if i were doing it i don't remember
flicking no
good but i say tapping cover is
what i do let's say one is okay yes and
then let's say 10 is an actual like you
just went all out i would say between 3
or five is the most i've ever
felt a force from me the officer
indicates olcheske would be put on paid
home duty the i-team asked ccsd for a
comment about the lawsuit and her dates
of employment a spokesperson said the
district doesn't comment on pending
litigation olcheske was charged eight
months later with six counts of child
abuse a criminal complaint states there
were six victims ages three and four
court records show she agreed to impulse
control counseling and community service
which resulted in a misdemeanor
conviction of disorderly conduct made me
just lose all faith and trust in not
only the justice system but the school
system and i shouldn't feel like that
the 8 news now i-team reached out to the
attorney who represented alchesky in the
criminal case he said he has no comment
vanessa murphy live local now
the 8 news now i-team also learned that
olcheske still has a teaching license in
our state